okay so this is our car okay
all right
okay so she has a key and she wants a
copy basically okay good great okay so
she's coming out right now okay
cool
yeah and he came out with a t-shirt
okay
all right now we
messed up that's funny okay so you want
the one with the remote
control is
Hunter okay okay
we got a 2013 Honda Fit
um customer has a key it's a
thing with Hondas they just fall apart
over time uh so we're gonna make her a
new key uh cut the blade program it
everything should be good to go I have a
key already so we're gonna let the
machine decode her key the customer's
key and once the key is decoded we can
actually
um cut our own key so basically we're
gonna select the correct key in the
machine and then we're gonna select the
code key
recorded the key I like to compare it to
the screen so kind of basically make
sure it looks correct uh if it looks
correct so I'm just gonna cut the uh
remote head key and then and I'm not
gonna cut a test key
all right so the key is cut now I'm
gonna program it without first make sure
it works so it works on the door
attention
all right two times the ignition okay so
now we just need to program the key
so with Hunters if we want to add a key
if we have a key and we want to add
another one so we're gonna put
the uh original key in the ignition
first and turn the ignition
without Smart Key
turn the ignition on
okay
and the key
turn off ignition
turn on ignition with the original key
now turn on ignition with the new key
off
without changing it on
on
now it's asking if the security light is
off it is so we're gonna press yes off
on with the original but it doesn't
matter anymore at this point and that's
it key is registered
so let's try to start the car
all right car starts and now we need to
program the remote
it's on board programming that means we
don't need any device the way it's gonna
work is I'm gonna put the key in the
ignition turn it on and off four times
every time the ignition will be on I
need to press the unlock button on the
fourth time the locks will cycle and
then the the key the remote will be
programmed okay so let's do it
on press on press on press on press okay
lock cycled
and that's it the key should be
programmed
okay
and
the remote works that's it job is done
the cheapest program and the remote is
programmed
and that's it let's make sure okay car
is locked car is unlocked all right
foreign
thank you guys have a good one